I'm not against relics, by the way.
I'm not against relics. You know why I'm
not against relics? Don't misunderstand
me and misquote me. The Bible says God
will use the relics of his holy ones.
Let me get into that real quick and
we're going to begin. So, anyway, I
don't know why I came into this here.
Does God use the relics of his holy ones
as saints? Yes. Will God use even the
bones of his saints? Yes. Will God even
use the coffin of his saints to bring
about Yes. Not I'm not against that. I
can't be because it's in scripture.
Okay.
Here you go. Just to name a few.
Right.
Here you go. Does God use relics? Yes.
Does God use the items of saints like
Jesus's robe or his tassels? Yes. Does
God use the bones of Yes. It's in the
Bible? Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
Here it is.
But when you tell me something belongs
to St. Joseph who went to be with Jesus
Christ 2,000 years ago. Come on now.
Let's be serious.
Can we be serious?
Right.
Yes, Moses staff. But here's one. He
used the bones of Elisha.
Elisha who had died. 2 Kings 13:201. Now
the bands of the Moabites invited the
land at the coming in of the year. As
they were burying a man, behold, they
saw a band of raiders, and they threw
the man into Elisha's tomb. As soon as
the man touched Elisha's bones, he
revived and stood up up on his feet. So
the bones of the prophet Elisha
resurrected a dead man. Now, who used
the bones to resurrect them? God did.
Who honored those bones to show that
this was a great man of God who had
God's approval? God. So, can we go to
let's say the tombs of St. Sherbel? Yes.
Can we ask his intercession to Jesus
Christ our Lord as we go to his tomb to
honor him that he was a great servant of
the Lord Jesus Christ and the God he
worshiped made him what he is? Yes, I'm
not against that. I can't because I find
it in scripture, right?
All right. How about here? Acts 5:14-16.
Peter, more believers were added to the
Lord, multitudes of both men and women.
They even carried out the sick into the
streets and laid them on CS and
mattresses so that as Peter came by, at
least his shadow might overshadow some
of them. God is even using the shadow of
Peter to cast out demons and heal the
sick. His shadow, how much more his body
if you touch it.
The multitude also came together from
the cities around Jerusalem, bringing
sick people, those who are tormented by
unclean spirits, and they were all
healed. If God will use the shadow of
Peter, how much more he'll use the body
of Peter, the relics of Peter, if
they're generally from Peter,
right?
Everyone got that?
How about this? Paul, Acts 19:11-12,
Paul's aprons and handkerchiefs.
The napkin he used anointed by the
spirit that filled him so that whatever
he touched became anointed by the power
of the Holy Spirit became sacred and now
became a means by which the spirit could
heal and deliver. How do I know? God
worked special miracles by the hands of
Paul. So even handkerchiefs or aprons
were carried away from his body to the
sick and the diseases departed from
them. The evil spirits went out. So if
the handkerchiefs and aprons touched and
used by a holy servant, a spiritfilled
servant of Jesus Christ will be
consecrated, anointed by the spirit
to heal people, deliver people. How much
more their bodies
So here is the biblical basis for relics
going see
and the oil right that drips from his
body.
It's biblical. That's not idolatrist.
That's not pagan. That's not what I'm
talking about. Right?
You over there.
So anyway,
my point in bringing us is it is
heart-wrenching, heartbreaking, even
disgusting to see
to see
people so biblically illiterate and
chasing after experiences. Because if
you're chasing after experience, what if
you see a miraculous
experience
dealing with another religion, Islam or
Hinduism? Will you then jump ship and
become Hindu or Muslim?
Here
NRA
watch here. Grave sucking. They went to
the grave of these so-called apostles
prophets to procure a blessing.
Grave sucking sucking video. See,
they're going on the to the tombs of
these people Bethl that they considered
holy people and just here like here to
try to suck the anointing from the dead
in their graves.
All right. How about here? Let's see.
Charismania
laughing
hysterically. Watch her. You're telling
me and then when I see this among
Catholics,
charismatics,
and you tell me I'm like, man, dude,
what is this?
Charismatics and Christian here. Look,
look at this.
>> HALLELUJAH.
THIS IS who God does.
[laughter]
>> Glory to God.
>> You're telling me this is a work of God,
huh?
Look.
>> Hallelujah.
[laughter]
>> Glory to God.
Notice Catholics, it's easy for you to
see this as something silly,
irreverent, unholy, wicked, if not
demonic, and mocks Jesus Christ. But
what if you see it among fellow
Catholics? Then what?
Watch here. Let's go here.
I don't want to get flagged. [laughter]
>> Hallelujah.
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> You think this is of God?
This fake preacher Kenneth Hagen.
But when you see it among Catholics, do
you condemn it as well or do you ignore
it because they're Catholics?
[laughter]
>> I think this glory.
Yeah. And you tell me this is of God,
huh?
Does this not look sick and demonic?
And people are outsiders who don't
believe. They're they're going to laugh
at Christianity.
Uh you'll be surprised, sister, at the
Catholic Charismatic Revival. Just look
into it.
Anyway, I don't want to get flagged. How
about them barking like dogs? Have you
seen those videos?
here. Barking like dogs. Look.
Hysterical.
Holy laughter. They call it holy
laughter.
How about this one? Let me play this.
This is worship, guys. This is worship.
Yeah. This is how the
This is how the apostles and the early
church set up worship.
>> [music]
>> Yeah. Yeah. This is worship, guys. This
is how
the [laughter]
the early apostles set up worship. This
is how the early church did their
worship
as they were focusing on the Eucharist,
right? But here, I want you to see that.
Barking like dogs. Barking like dogs
here. Here.
What you you get ready? You want to get
ready to get sick? I just hope I don't
get
flagged. Yeah, Adam. I hope not. Watch
here.
Okay. That's that's that's that's
Christianity. Yeah. She's barking like a
dog and his guys This is uh
Christianity. This is
gifts of the spirit.
Really?
They take Toronto something.
>> All right.
So, this is what I left. I came out of
meaning when I see this. So, when I have
Catholics, I'm being honest. When I have
Catholic come to me and I see they're so
excessive in experience, they'll travel
miles. They'll fly for hours to these,
let's say, getaways where they're going
to be
looking for these miraculous encounters
and they don't know a lick of scripture.
They don't know a lick of scripture.
Bothersome.
Bothersome. Let me see if I can find
some of the C. Then we're going to
begin. I promise you. Catholic
troublesome,
right?
Let's see
if I can find it.
I don't know if I can.
Yeah, I don't know if I say I can. I
made I don't know if I can but and
nonetheless
silliness. Let's see if I can find
silliness
if they can something right here. if
they do something silly and foolish.
Any I can't find one here, but here just
to show you the difference. Here you
have Matt Brad interviewing,
right? Father Mark Goring, who's all
pro-atholic
charismatic
revivalist. So now here you have him,
Father Mark Goring, who's all for the
Catholic Charismatic movement. And then
I'll bring you Catholics who are all
against it.
Nonetheless, let you you get the point.
Maybe in the future, right here, say to
him, I'll play some clips of Catholic
charismatic abuses as well.